Santa's a great line in the film Freight
by IP factors name is rizwan mangy who
played moh and he looks at you bruh ham
and he says be careful the people that
flew those planes into the building they
look like us what do you hope the
Western culture will gain from seeing
the film well let me talk about what I
what I hope you know more than this
specific line because this is out of
fear and this is out of an immediate
reaction and this is who humo which is
was played by respond manager I think it
is fantastic job you know showing this
this character in the movie when I think
I would the citizen is as a message of
hope peace and tolerance and this is
what I hope people get out of it it's
basically we're trying to build better
understanding so we don't fear each
other I think I mean I think building
you know a better knowledge in an
understanding make us make us know who
we are and who they are and we can get
along together because the timing i
believe this this world is big enough to
it to you know to contain i maintain
everybody and have everybody and we can
all live you know in a you know in a
peaceful environment so this is what i
feel you know the citizen is is kind of
like as the main main message of n the
entire movie is is really you know
building this cultural bridge and
telling people how how perhaps looked at
nine eleven how you know they they they
approach you know the events and you
know and there are different kind of
people i mean as khalid mission a mean
they're not only that you know that the
hijackers and who did you know who did
in the 911 but there are a lot of good
people successful people in this you
know in this country who believed in and
you know and believed in
and in this country and believe in the
Constitution and follow rules and pay
taxes and you know and having you know I
get good a great life here so this is
what I what I feel you know the citizen
is all about
you